[Music]
[Music]
installation seven otherwise known as
zeta halo was originally created at the
greater arc and is the only surviving
ring of the original array of twelve
halos
having been created at the greater arc
it was three times the size of a typical
halo ring standing at 30 000 kilometers
in diameter
like the other halos installation 7 had
a secondary purpose as a forerunner life
worker preserve for biological specimens
from across the galaxy
installation 7 was primarily dedicated
to humans and was the home to various
species and subspecies of the human
genus
the humans living there were mostly left
untouched by the forerunners and went on
to build their own societies and cities
during the forerunner flood war master
builder faber placed installation 7 as
well as the other 11 rings in the
original array under control of the most
advanced 4runner ai available mendicant
bias
sometime following this the master
builder broke his deal with the
librarian and began to use the humans on
the installation in his experiments on
the flood
some of the life workers followed the
master builder's plans while the rest
continued to keep the biological
preserve safe
approximately 60 years after the master
builder had begun as unsanctioned
experiments he charged mendicant bias
with test-firing installation 7 in
charum hako's system
this lead to an entity called the
primordial to be released from a cell
within an asteroid on the outside of the
galaxy
the master builder ordered the
primordial to be brought onto the ring
where they could study it
the life workers had no idea what the
creature was
some believed it to be related to the
flood while others thought it was
something else
the master builder then assigned
mendicant bias to interrogate the
primordial
they would discover that it was
supposedly the last surviving precursor
an ancient advanced race that was
responsible for the seeding of life
across multiple galaxies
millions of years ago the forerunners
one of their creations stood up against
them and drove them to near extinction
the primordia was able to convince the
ai of the wrong doings of his masters
and turn him over to his side
on top of this the creature also managed
to manipulate the master builder
over time the master builder reduced the
role of the life workers locking them
down into smaller groups of humans while
he continued with his experimentation
as more and more humans were taken the
societies began to collapse
people were abandoning the cities going
into hiding through fear that they would
be the next ones the forerunners would
take away
eventually mitigate bias would open up
the flood containment facilities on the
installation
allowing it to spread across the ring
planet
[Music]
after installation 7 had officially been
considered missing for 43 years
the mast builder had a second halo ring
transported to the san xion world and
proceeded to activate the ring to
suppress the rebellion
the majority of the seng xiaoyou were
completely wiped out
however the repercussions of this action
led to many of the forerunners in his
service to openly rebel against the
master builder seeing it as an offence
to the mantle of responsibility that
they live by
while the rebellion was quickly dealt to
it created further divide among the
security forces and life workers under
his control with several continuing to
resist through sabotaging facilities in
an attempt to bring down the
installation from the inside
but once news of the master builder's
use of the halo ring against the san xiu
reached the council he was arrested and
put on trial on matrilian the forerunner
capital world
during the master builders trial the
halo rings were gathered in orbit over
the capital including installation seven
dominican bias managed to activate its
other extensions on five of the other
halo rings and used them to push back
the capital's forces in turn releasing
the master builder
however the supreme commander of the
forerunner war efforts the iso didact
was able to use a control code to
temporarily stun the ai allowing the
capital's defenses to respond to the
attack
although they put up a valiant fight
against the sentinels and ships
defending the installations mendicant
bias was able to successfully activate
the ring's main weapon wiping out all
life on the capital world
following the battle at the capital
installation 7 activated a security
measure that was beyond the control of
the mintakin bias
this protocol was put in place to
prevent the facility from falling into
the wrong hands
it had been programmed to run on a
course that would result in a collision
with a planet with the automated control
systems having been sabotaged mendicant
bias was unable to change the course
using the humans and forerunners support
the installation they were sent to
various control stations across the halo
ring in an attempt to manually steer it
away from the planet
they were successful in changing the
orientation of the ring in a way where
the planet would pass through the centre
though installation 7 would take heavy
damage it would survive the encounter
as the ring passed over the planet's
gravitational pull began to bend and
distort the installation's outer walls
huge gaps started opening up some
hundreds of kilometers long
it was during this time that a fleet led
by the iso diadect appeared
he once again used his control codes to
shut down mindigan bias
using his fleet he was able to pump
extra power into the installation and
connect to the controls
the iso didact observed the massive
damage that had been taken and made the
call to shed large sections of the ring
and rebuild what could be saved
in the end two-thirds of the structure
was removed and discarded into
space installation seven now had a total
diameter of ten thousand kilometers
which also meant that it could be now
sent to the lizard for repairs
most of the installations surviving
biological specimens including humans
were saved by the life workers and
relocated to the ark
mendicant biases core on the
installation was deactivated while the
ai itself was forced to undergo a
process to correct its rampancy
the primordial was captured and placed
in a cage deep underneath the
installation surface
there the didact interrogated the being
before eventually executing it
the majority of the flood remained on
the ring and were watched over by
monitors
by order of the didact the halo was
eventually sent through a slip space
portal to remain as a memorial to the
millions of beings that have died there
at the conclusion of the forerunner
flood war installation 7 was activated
along with the other six rings in the
final halo array wiping out all life
within a radius of 25 000 light years
the next few sections will have spoilers
for the halo infinite story so if you
haven't finished the game yet you may
want to switch off
in 2555 the office of naval intelligence
initiated the zeta halo project
300 scientists in multiple fields were
sent to the installation to study the
halo
eventually a 4runner timer was
discovered and it was counting down to
installation 7's activation in 5 weeks
time
reports followed showing that the other
rings in the array were also showing
these countdowns
this triggered a joint unsc sangee
operation on the lesser arc to find a
way to stop the activation
by 2558 there were 3 416 humans on the
ring 406 were scientists with the
remainder being military personnel
in 2559 during the conflict with cortana
and the created installation 7 became
the center of a large battle between the
unsc and the banished
it was decided that the only way to put
a stop to the rogue ai plans was to have
her terminated
this led to the creation of an ai called
the weapon
it had one purpose
to delete cortana
the plan was to get the weapon into
installation seven systems where she
would lie and wait for cortana
when the time was right she would ambush
and shut her down
meanwhile the banished under atriox
leadership was sorting revenge against
cortana after she had completely
destroyed the geralhane
homeworld was while he was on the lesser
arc the atriox had learned of the
secrets being held on installation seven
secrets that would give the banished a
huge advantage over their enemies
it was the banished who arrived on the
ring planet first they were able to
fortify with troops and establish
anti-air weapons
when the unsc finally arrived it was
immediately ambushed by the banished
fleet and boarded
while the unsc was successful in
deploying the weapon
their forces were quickly overwhelmed
eventually the order was given to
abandon the infinity
the infinity and multiple unsc frigates
were destroyed by the banished
the majority of the survivors seeking to
land on the ring were killed due to the
heavy anti-air fire
those who were successful were scattered
across the land
this was a huge defeat for the unsc
meanwhile cortana had arrived and was
successfully trapped by the weapon where
she would remain until the master chief
was able to collect her and take her
back to the infinity for deletion
however the infinity is now gone and the
master chief has since had a battle with
atriox that saw him defeated and killed
in the process
atriox then attempts to gain control
over cortana getting her to hand over
the ring
but the rogue ai now seeing that her
attempts at bringing peace were
misguided decides to make things right
by not allowing the ring to fall into
banished hands
she sacrificed herself to destroy a
large section of the ring taking atriox
with her
at some point during the battle the
installation had moved to an unknown
system rendering all of the stranded
unsc survivors unable to call in for
reinforcements
however it was the same for the banished
though their numbers were considerably
larger
over the following month the banished
now led by atriox's second in command
and mentor esharum hunted down the
remaining unsc forces on the ring while
investigating its secrets
in 2560 the master chief was discovered
by unsc pilot
he was floating around space near the
ring
[Music]
presumed dead the pilot was able to
bring his systems back online
with the help of the pilot the master
chief would then return to the surface
of installation seven
he would rally the surviving unsc forces
and put a stop to the banished by
eliminating isharam and many of his top
commanders
they would discover that the banished
had released a member of an advanced
race called the harbinger who had been
imprisoned on the ring hundreds of
thousands of years ago by the
forerunners
the harbinger was one of a species known
as the endless
after the forerunners discovered that
they were immune to the effects of the
halo ring they deemed them as a threat
and sealed them on installation 7.
the harbinger made a deal with ishiram
to return the ring to operational status
if he would help him release the fellow
members of his species trapped within
however after a lengthy battle the
master chief was able to take her down
removing the threat of countless others
of a kind being released
he now continues on his mission of
removing the remaining banished forces
from the ring
but there is one last surprise
not only had atriox survived
he had been working in secret with the
harbinger
and by using the information she had
acquired
atriox had finally discovered the
location of the imprisoned endless
i will inform the criterion to proceed
they believe we are here to help
it matters not
today we do what it takes to maintain
order
to
[Music]
we can control and we cannot allow it to
be theirs
[Music]
if halo cannot end them it must imprison
them
when it is done
the engineers will be busy
we will learn their secrets
oh yeah fear and i cannot do this alone
you shall not be alone the criterion has
given the order
offensive bias has been deployed
[Music]
you